now they'll get it
breaks through the basketball we see
[Applause]
step-back jumper
in the air but then you're basically ad
lib adoption contestants with hot good
steel miles power takes it home
[Applause]
had it now it's up with young and his
town with the first person point to the
game
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
opportunities for Marquette Powell's
gorgeous
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
shot clock attend stolen by games
Winston gets it back shot clock at 8
Winston
Winston
often times his Paul to foul
time to shoot livers try to stay right
with them the intercept to play it to
Winston a little bit of this a little
bit of that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Howard Jones finish Dan halogen snatches
it out of the air here comes the Marcus
Howard pulls up from deep
[Applause]
again a deep three
[Applause]
get Squad ended last season the regular
season with four straight losses coming
into this game five of six seven to
shoot
[Music]
Howard
[Applause]
a shot from Marcus holler with time
winding down defended now by slugs with
Marshall out of the game
shot clock
are you kidding
yeah post up our Melo wife never gets
the ball door marked this deep down into
snack 12 history the crossover wall
three seconds
Prichard has to hoist
Oh sturdy up for a second here before he
has to fade back dylon courageous
three-second differential between the
shot game clock is protected Richard
long three he took often go rebound but
he really could occur it's a great pass
the left-handed on the offensive end I
think they'll be able to hurt them with
their size with the penetration control
that he puts it through seven points
early competing
[Applause]
then from the Danes gotten from the sip
see Blaine as a pool she's down low
there's the broom Center down to Sosa
tracks it down now what a pass inside
and doubt the big global story
again to the carrot as a Ange
size-wise exactly
[Applause]
to get into motion but its motion
offense a lot of down screen back screen
fade screen the two switches very
tyloo turns your booty